dead cells is a game that just recently
came out of early access and what do you
know I was given a copy of the game
first time for everything I've had a lot
of fun playing it so far so I thought
I'd give my two cents on it bear in mind
that this is coming from someone who
didn't have to actually pay for the game
firstly it is in no way shape or form a
Souls like it advertises quote souls
light combat not souls like souls light
and action in the sense that it is quote
tough but fair but I think this is a
pretty big stretch which I don't really
get the game is great on its own so the
devs don't need to try and string a
Souls comparison when it really isn't
needed I would never consider dead cells
combat to be souls like or souls light
or any other souls like like word but
I'll get more into that once we actually
understand what the game is so let's
explain what that cells is as the steam
page says it's a rogue light
Metroidvania there's that word light
again okay maybe the death is just like
the word light a lot the core elements
that define this game are the features
that would qualify it to be a roguelike
and those that would qualify it to be a
Metroidvania the devs have also opted to
coin and use rogue dania as a descriptor
get it like rogue light and Metroidvania
which I guess is apt but makes me wonder
how many game names in genres we can add
into one word until we arrive at our own
video game ship of theseus in the past
year or so I've gotten to play some
great games there would actually be
really relevant in comparing to dead
cells hollow night for the metroidvania
side and Binding of Isaac and enter the
gungeon for the rogue side I really
enjoyed all of those games and think
that there are some great modern takes
on their respective genres I wouldn't be
afraid to speak of dead cells in a
similar breath as those games so if
you've played them that should give you
a picture of my attitude Island dead
cells going into this video so let's
break each side of this rogue Vania down
in suit a Metroidvania x' each level in
dead cells is like a labyrinth you
explore and weave your way through as
you go you may discover power-ups or
dead ends or mini-bosses or anything in
between there is a constant need to
backtrack and sometimes areas and
enemies will be different on the second
go-around though the tediousness or
meticulous nest depending on how you
look at it of traditional Metroidvania
backtracking is not to present in dead
cells because of the plethora of
teleportation stations you probably come
across one every 10 seconds and each one
lets you teleport to any other one
you've revealed letting you move between
the entire explored map relatively
instantly so it's not sticking to the
metroidvania formula completely which
makes sense it's not a Metroidvania it's
a rogue vania now we're going to start
treading into the rogue territory a bit
in debt cells the gameplay is instant
out in runs as you progress through the
levels if you die you lose all your
required weapons power-ups and
currencies in this case the currencies
are gold and cells they're sent all the
way back to the start and have to
restart the whole run-through if you're
familiar with binding of issac or enter
the gungeon
then this concept of runs is just the
same and like those games in each run
you'll unlock and pick up items and
power-ups that change your attacks and
increase your damage or other stats you
can also unlock certain things that
remain permanently unlocked even across
deaths which alter gameplay however back
to the metroidvania land these permanent
unlocks are more significant than in
traditional rogue lights and that they
have much more broader consequences
there are things like giving you the
ability to permanently access a new zone
heal multiple times instead of once or
Never consistently find better gear and
drops and progress faster overall and
just to flesh out my description a bit
as you progress through the levels
you'll find new weapons gadgets and
grenades that you adopt a variety of
different playstyles especially when
paired with choosing which of your three
stats you want to level most of the
weapons and gadgets do damage directly
correlated with the level of your stats
red weapons do higher damage the more
the red skill is leveled and the same
goes with the other two colors each
color also has a general focus for
example red as a focus on higher damage
and green has a focus on higher
sustainability more HP and HP recovery
now that we have a working idea of what
constitutes this rogue dania known as
dead cells let's talk about gameplay and
how this game is the darksouls of games
that aren't like dark souls and
shouldn't be compared to dark souls
first off the similarities you have an
invincible role you have limited heals
that were filled chuck
points moving on to differences you have
no stamina bar the game is 2d you have
no light or heavy attacks there are no
proper weapon upgrade trees leveling is
based on item pickups not killing
enemies and the biggest one is that the
combat is not slow and deliberate it's
really fast and if I can save this
without any negative connotation its
spammy when I'm hitting scrubs I'm
mashing my x and y buttons as fast as I
can and I don't mean to say this is a
bad thing I really enjoy the fast pace
when I get into a good rhythm of slicing
enemies and zipping through the map the
game shines brilliantly even the heavier
slower weapons still give themselves to
a certain speed of progressing through
the level as you may only need to hit
enemies once or twice which means you
can keep up the overall pace this is at
odds with the souls mentality of slow
and deliberate as I mentioned before I
would describe running through the
worlds of lothric or Lordran as a fairly
meticulous experience and the combat of
souls games is such that you always have
to be careful because one hit could lead
to your demise dead cells is all about
keeping up pace the game even rewards
you generously for reaching upper levels
in a short amount of time this is a core
difference in design philosophy that I
think really demarcates dead cells as
novice Souls like in any significant way
if we look at other games that bear the
colorful moniker of souls like we'll see
games like the Serge and Nia which fall
much much more on the side of the souls
series slow and deliberate combat and
this isn't to say that you don't have to
be careful in dead cells combat or that
dead cells combat isn't high-stakes the
one hit can lead you to a pretty bad
situation but I think it's two of
different levels in Dark Souls because
the dead cells is supposed to be played
at a faster speed it simply doesn't play
like a Souls game it can be challenging
and my heart rate went through the roof
the first time I vanquished the bosses
but that's just a mark of a game with
satisfying combat not a Souls like or
derivative I really don't want to see
reviews and websites talking about how
this game shares attributes with Souls
sure that they will especially because
the developers do another aspect of the
gameplay that I want to talk about is
the enemy telegraphing system because of
the style of the game most of the
enemies have a very explicit Telegraph
right before they attack in the form of
an exclamation mark popping up above
them
I assume this is because most enemies
don't occupy much of the screen space so
assuming that the player would actually
be able to see the enemies is less
obvious movement Telegraph's would be
putting too much on the player
especially when there are multiple
enemies or a lot of particle effects
going on I understand why this would be
done as if players didn't have it they
could very well get mad that there isn't
a quote fair way to know when each enemy
is going to attack even though most
enemies do have an actual natural
Telegraph generally in the form of
winding up their attack in some way have
purely natural Telegraph's though I
don't know how plausible that would be
in a game like this it works well in the
souls games because the enemies in those
games are much larger relative to the
screen so they're much easier to see I
would think I'd be able to manage it in
game without the extra exclamation mark
is a lot of the National Telegraph's
are pretty decently shown so it's a
great but it's not the biggest one now
the replayability of the game due to its
roguelike run based design is a pretty
big plus to me it's the same kind of
thing as Binding of Isaac or enter the
gungeon with the games based around
repeatedly playing through the same
levels to make this not a boring slog
pick up some power-ups spawn differently
and each level is never the exact same
ever and from this procedural generation
is used to achieve this I think it's
used really well in this case you always
know generally what a level is like
after you've been through it but you're
never going to be running the exact same
corridors or memorizing maps to be fair
I haven't gotten to the late-game yet so
I can't say how it completely holds up
but it seems like dead cells does a
pretty good job of keeping high
replayability you need many many hours
of content on to some other aspects of
the game the aesthetics is high level
notch
visual design graphics sound design and
soundtracks are all done quite well the
atmospheres of each level are extremely
distinct and the art and music
immediately make that a reality
pixel art can sometimes be a hit or miss
with devs sometimes going really
simplistic with
number of pixels and amount of detail
dead cells doesn't have an immense
amount of detail but it does have enough
for it to not be a detriment the layered
design from foreground to double
distance background thanks traversing
back and forth in each level feel
dynamic and helps bring the world to
life the player design is unique
compared to the world so you stand out
enough to always be decently sure of
where you are though you don't take up
that much of the screen and with a
couple enemies launching attacks at you
the effects can get pretty intense there
have been a few times where I felt like
I lost where I was but it hasn't been a
major problem the enemy designs are
irrelevant coming across a new enemy
feels like a surprise because they're
generally unlike anything previously
seen the sounds are mostly good at doing
their job and the music always helps
build the atmosphere I don't have any
strong opinion either way about the
sounds they're decent and fulfilled what
they need to do but I do think the music
was created and chosen intelligently
because most of the levels are so
distinct they should have music that
helps illustrate those distinctions and
it does the seaside almost jaunty tunes
that accompany pirate zombies of the
stilt village are quite at odds with the
percussion heavy driving soundtrack of
the ramparts as they should be because
those are completely different thematic
zones this again helps the world feel
much more alive than it otherwise would
have without these features I should
probably discuss the story - it's there
but it's easy to miss most of the story
is learning about the lore of the island
that the game takes place on and the
different zones this is often done in
loading screens before each zone it's
definitely a more minor feature in my
opinion but it does give context to a
lot of the areas you explore and fight
in so it does help with the immersion
and world building of it all even if
it's to a small extent the player
character seems to have a good sense of
humor to him/her it that makes for some
slightly comical interactions which
helps lift the mood in an often intense
game overall the game has character you
can tell there was a clear design that
was faithfully executed with the result
being a unique and satisfying experience
I would give dead cells as a solid
recommendation especially to anyone who
has played or enjoyed Metroidvania or
roguelikes
it's pretty easy to jump into and it has
a lot in terms of content and room
master the combat satisfying gameplay
coupled with a nice aesthetic package
makes Ted sells a solid grab even if it
isn't a 2d Dark Souls